why varèse aren't born in one fight
whether it be against a frenemy or an
arc villain some of the most engaging
aspects of anime are the multiple fights
featuring a plucky protagonist rematches
are a nice way to gauge character
progression through arcs and it's a good
way to give something to fans to look
forward to after all wouldn't you want
to see your now stronger hero once again
taking on the enemy who stomped him a
while ago it's indeed these rematches
that give birth to some of the most
legendary rivalries that we've grown to
love so they take a look at some of the
top anime rematches in history
crocodile and Luffy had their fair share
of run-ins during the alabaster Ark in
that Ark they had three fights and while
Luffy put up better showings in each
fight the powerful warlord would keep
putting him down decisively make no
mistake the fights against crocodile
have final boss fight vibes written all
over it and the master of sand seems
nyam beatable all things considered
except for one factor come the third
fight our hero finds a way to get over
the hump for all his seeming
invincibility crocodile has one a major
weakness water Luffy uses this single
most effective weapon against his
nemesis getting into his head one could
say that Luffy had plot armor for this
fight but we can also argue that
crocodile was defeated because he lost
his cool he lunges at Luffy and puts
himself into the only position the straw
hats leader could win overall this makes
for a nice smart final fight where it
certainly didn't feel too as Polly
[Applause]
[Music]
Shonen goodness doesn't end there with
our next fight being ichigo vs. Grimmjow
as is traditional for shown in series
the start of a new arc means the heroes
all powers are usually obsolete or power
croocked by a new villain bleach is no
exception with ichigo's bang Chi which
he spent many episodes mastering quickly
being matched and eclipsed by a new kind
of enemy in this case it's Grimmjow who
gives him and Rukia a beating after
revealing himself to be one of those
Shinigami hollow hybrids the Aizen had
talked so passionately about the to come
face to face again inside hueco mundo
this time ready to reveal new power-ups
of their own Ichigo comes to terms with
his inner hollow while Grimmjow is all
but ready to whip out the Arrancar
version of Bank ie the two collide in a
back-and-forth fight that shares
similarities to the last Renji fight
carrying his resolve to not only defeat
Grimmjow but also Eisen and ulquiorra
ichigo overcomes the arrancars claw
blades and finishes the fight with a
decisive slash
[Music]
let's not start with the shounen jump
titles at 2 in 8 is the rematch between
fo and send o the two had a classic
match in their first bout and one would
doubt whether they'd recreate the magic
with a second fight all doubts are
raised when they get into the ring again
with the resulting fight being one of
the best ever in the series he had
everything you could ask for the fight
had that magical big match appeal and
viewers are on the edge with every fight
and false finish the music was simply
the icing on the cake if I'm not
mistaken and this fight was originally
supposed to be an ending point for the
series which could explain the whole
final boss feel that the fight had all
over it with that possibility in mind it
could explain why the fights so good is
designed to be the best fight of the
series to send everyone off happy with
an amazing series
[Music]
[Music]
need I say it achilles versus Kieran
round twos by far one of the best
sequences you'll see in faith series
with good ol hand-to-hand combat
goodness it's a fight that makes you
want to see it keep going
you've seen a psycho past his famous
hand-to-hand battle and I think this
fights on par with that one if not
better you can feel the energy and the
force with each punch and hit delivered
by the two fighters in their prime their
previous encounters leave a lot to be
desired but we can see Achilles slowly
making headway in overcoming the wall
that prevented him from fighting his
former friend out right in this final
battle the gloves are off and we're
treated to possibly the best payoff for
a rivalry between friends
we're tighten let's just say the early
Aaron doesn't have the cleanest win-loss
record previously in the episodes more
known for the deaths of Petra and the
other members of the Levi's squad
there was this one fight between Aaron
and the female Titan transformed by rage
in carrying all his unbridled fury with
him aaron attacks the female titan only
to get absolutely destroyed
this ain't fairy tale man knock on my
power won't get you anywhere just ask
those guys from the Levi's squad Aaron
actually got beaten so bad that he kind
of pulled a Hulk way before infinity war
but not this time with the female Titan
once again on the attack after some
struggles in bringing the inner Titan
out aaron springs into action once again
if you need any more indication of how
strong the female Titan was in
comparison to Eren this fight should
have raised all doubts even in this
rematch and he still gets the upper hand
on her opponent however this time aaron
has the right backup that he needed with
the serve a corpse intervention annie
finally falls against the might of
humanity rendering her in a state of
being trapped inside a crystal
rematches are the best if the two
characters have chemistry with one
another what better pair to have that
chemistry than the childhood friends
midoriya and buck will go with vastly
different backgrounds personalities and
life trajectories it comes as no
surprise that the two former childhood
friends would butt heads once more upon
their reunion as teens the two battled
in one of the most emotional fights in
the Provisional hero license exam ugh
back and forth they went at it with
midoriya even getting to show off some
nifty new tricks with his quirk in the
end bakugan merged as the surprise
victor but he doesn't find any joy in
the victory as he's confronted by all
might with the harsh truth at the end
[Music]
our next lucky winner this time is the
rematch between Lancer and Archer in
unlimited blade works I'm willing to bet
that Cruz one of the strongest servants
in the fate/stay night time line you're
talking about a guy who made Gilgamesh
work half a day for victory in another
route in ubw he's no slouch either as a
second encounter with Archer allows him
to finally show off his true
capabilities no longer held back by
anything Lancer goes all-out in his bid
to defeat Archer sparks fly-in
explosions about as the two strong
servants go the distance
showing off pretty much everything in
their arsenal had it not been for
archers sheer experience and resourceful
Nassim battle the fight would have been
over quickly in favor of Kubb give
credit to Archer too though not a lot
can survived a bulk row is barely
managed to block it and save him by the
teeth but it's nonetheless impressive
for him to be able to stop the Ultima
spear
[Music]
[Music]
both beings have questionable morals and
perfect falls for each other
it seems that Alucard and Anderson were
simply made for each other they had
their first encounter early on and it
was too bad that Integra had to rob us
of an epic looking fight that was just
about to begin it took a while before
their final fight and boy did it deliver
coming at each other with their full
strength and to unleash their furious
attacks in succession in a touch-and-go
battle the match is a key highlight of
the series and it featured a lot of
run-ins newly-revealed forms and twists
in the end Alucard stands tall and
anderson never really stood a chance in
a straighter battle although one can
argue that even anderson himself saw his
defeat coming a mile away
nevertheless who could refuse the chance
to settle things with your rival once
and for all
[Music]
in the next chapter of possibly animes
most iconic rivalries Goku takes on
Marjan Vegeta when this battle came out
it was one of the most anticipated
battles in the Dragon Ball series
featuring the much awaited rematch
between Goku and Vegeta this isn't just
a battle it's an illustration of how far
these characters have come it may not be
a death battle like the first fight but
it has more to it than what people
typically give it credit for
personally the fight had all the
elements of a classic DBZ fight but I'd
like to focus on the surprising depth
this fight had Goku actually had access
to ssj3 but held back well we can also
see how far Vegeta had gone in his mad
quest for power I think some are
disappointed by the fight because of
hindsight as knowing that Goku could
have easily won and just allowed his
opponent to fight him on an equal field
seems to cheapen everything but as I
said I actually think that knowledge
improved my opinion of the fight given
the reasons above
we cap off this list with probably the
most storied fighting Shonen anime
history naruto vs sasuke these two have
been through a lot haven't they destined
to be rivals whose fates intertwined
naruto and sasuke had their decisive
final showdown at the end of the series
throughout err Sasuke's been that one
major obstacle that one wall to climb
that one symbol the stands obviously
everything that a jumpsuit wearing ninja
stands for it's only fitting that they
had one final battle after all Naruto
did spend half the series looking for
Sasuke and their previous confrontations
have generally ended in Sasuke favor
this time with Madara and Kaguya taking
care of Naruto has one last thing left
to do not the edge out of his old buddy
fittingly the latter has the same idea
and fight they did they put on a show to
be remembered coming at each other with
the peak evolution of their powers
Naruto and Sasuke fought to a technical
draw in the end Naruto was awarded the
technical win as the former friend
turned enemy finally relented and made
peace with his eternal rival and that
just about wraps it up care to tell me
which one of these rematches is your
favorite maybe you could suggest another
rematch for me to include who knows a
vol.2 might be on the way sooner than
you'd expect for more content like this
make sure to stay tuned in addition to
these top-10 lists I'm actually thinking
of creating even more new content to
make your 2020 a great one what could it
be only one way to find out hit the like
and subscribe button as well as the Bell
button I'll see you next time on mini
tube
[Music]
[Music]